hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends of chess tournament
with this is here from the previous
video with a very nice game between
Roush wonõt an island and the Magnus
Carlsen this is game four and the
previous three games have ended in a
draw they were all very intense and in
one game Anand was even sort of in a
winning position but in Indian the game
ended in a draw so here Anand with the
white pieces whoever wins wins the match
or if it's a row they go into Armageddon
so Anand witted the white pieces opens
with E 4 and the Magnus when he wants to
play a save game when he doesn't want to
you know give white too many chances
goes for his he 5 and of course we are
most likely to see the Berlin if it was
you know a game that he was planning to
win or something most likely he would go
for the Sicilian so tonight of three we
have Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 rule
opus is on the board we have Knight to
f6 going for the Berlin defense and d3
now now with Bishop to c5 by Magnus and
now captures on c6 so the this is
basically today's mainline Knight bTW -
and Bishop to g4 now just continuing
development we have h3 challenging the
bishop and the bishop to age 5 and now
Knight to c4 so here Anand is doing
something different he wants the Castle
queenside black will most likely also
Castle queenside and we're gonna have a
bit of a different game so here we have
Knight to d7 as usually you want to
bring this Knight to c4 to get a double
attack on the e5 pawn and the Magnus
goes back nice to d7 and now as this
night is still pinned there is no danger
of losing the e5 pawn so Bishop e3 by
Anand and not f6 also another signature
move of the Berlin strengthening e5 and
here there is one game in the database
where Queen d2 was played but here we
have Queen to e2 by Anand and it is as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game so Magnus continues with Queen e7
and both players Castle queenside so
castles castles and now to prophylactic
moves in a row
King bee 1 followed by King to be a so a
bit of a bit of a mimicry going on
here and here we have a very interesting
night seat to beat you trying to trying
to see how Magnus will react to this the
night can be transferred maybe to f12 g3
to f5 and so on but Magnus replies with
Bishop to b6 and a nun just goes back
Knight to c4 he wants the trade night
for Bishop but he doesn't want to trade
dark square Bishop for darks for a
bishop with something like this so
Buster back the c5 magnitude of course
enjoy a trade here so he can activate
his queen and now he's basically asking
on and are you happy with a threefold
repetition here and I'm just getting a
draw so we can take this into Armageddon
with the same repetition Knight back to
d2 there should be 694 Bishop c5 Knight
CD 2 and so on however on and of course
is not interested in squandering his
white pieces you know in less than 50
moves so he goes for g4 we rush up to f7
by Magnus and now Knight f2 d2
now if of course you capture here the
knight can recapture so nice to f8 by
Magnus then I can now come to g6 and
then to f4 f4 is a very nice outpost for
for the night and f4 by white now we
Bishop captures on e3 by Magnus Queen
captures and mountain Knight to g6
putting pressure on the pawn here and
now F characters on e5 f5 is also a
possibility but Anand has a different
idea
so if characters with F captures and
rook beat the f1 now he wants the double
rooks along the F file as that's where
all the game is going to going to happen
so Bishop e6 getting the bishop out of
the the open F file and now Queen to g3
now with a double attack on the pawn
here for the moment you don't really
you're not really threatening anything
here because even if black played
something weird you can't really capture
because of this check and then you just
lose a queen so not really a threat
right away but it can be at some point
so here we have rook h2 f8
Magnus just continues developing and now
Knight back to e3
so this Knight is now coming to five and
that is an excellent outpost for the
Knights the f4 square on the other hand
is an excellent outpost for the earth
this night
so here quinta c5 first before going for
this Knight to f4 idea honor trades once
along the F file CalPERS captures and
now here anon goes Knight to f5 now here
this is one one moment where the threat
is actually stronger than the execution
and he sort of falls into Carlson's
little trap that calls and set with this
Queen to see if I move he plays the Dean
Knight to f5 move let's say I move one
move too early so feel free to pause the
video now and take advantage of this
move with black while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
that were able to do it congratulations
on supporting the the cheapo mentioned
in the title and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's Bishop
captures on a - it's just nicely
grabbing a pawn point is if you move
King to c1 then you've just given up a
pawn and you can just let it play
something like this open up the King and
the play play to play this kind of a
game so on and accept the challenge he
plays keen capture Sonny - but now Queen
a5 check and now you just win back your
piece and you've snatched a pawn clean
so King b1 and now Queen captures on V -
and now you while you could capture on
g7 it's not really worth it for example
knife captures rook f2 and you already
have a lot of problems here now you have
to go into passivity with the district
and you're already doing pretty pretty
poorly you don't want to play passive
moves and now maybe just you know
pushing here is sufficient to get the
job done so here instead
anin goes for h4 he wants to play h5 g5
and may try and make something happen
there hopefully get an open H file for
his rook
so Magnus goes for rook to f7 now he
defends it he doesn't have to worry
about his g7 pawn anymore and h5 so
Knight to f4 and this is an excellent
square for the knight and g5 now going
for this g6 idea and now a5 at some
point you want to start pushing this so
it does make sense and here
Ronen could go for g6 let's say captures
captures and then let's say rook f8 not
allowing any checks and
you don't want to capture right away
because rook here just attacks the night
and after it moves you will be able to
pick up the g6 pawn but it is it is a
very dynamic and interesting position
and black constantly has to worry about
this however Anand goes for tonight's
the e3 instead and now comes Queen to b4
by Magnus again you could play b5 a4 and
start pushing like this but Magnus has a
different idea
now a4 a3 is the plan and just checkmate
on b2 so of course on it has to worry
about that we have Knight to c4 and a
for Magnus just wants to get this point
as close as possible here and here you
could even capture the pawn on e5 then
we get a three threatening checkmate
Knight moves back to defend and after
captures you play this it's not very
pleasant but it is sort of sort of
playable you will be able to kick away
the Queen with Queen to e1 and continue
playing this but I decided to go for g6
first we have h characters H characters
and now rook to f6 by Magnus with a
double attack on this pawn here and here
Anand basically has no other choice you
should go for a knife capped for Sonny I
need 5 as ugly as it is followed by a 3
and 94 to defend checkmate and after
this just go for this end game with
Quinta e1 so after this it gets traded
off rook captures on g6 King captures
here we get this end game where Magnus
has a past G pawn he is up upon but it's
also a CC pawn so maybe maybe white will
be able to hold this however Island went
for rook the h8 check we have King the
a7 and now now Anand played Queen to g4
and Queen to g4 we reach the position
from the thumbnail as the night covers
this there are some ideas of Queen c8
followed by Queen to aah checkmate but
there is a problem this move completely
blunders the game for the last time feel
free to pause the video and the window
game for Magnus well I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful mating sequence although it's
extremely difficult to find and for
those who just wanna enjoy to show its
Quinta II one check of course everyone
thought of that move what follows next
is the the beauty of the idea King a two
and now Knight character Sundy three and
now you don't really have any any
options if you if you don't capture the
night there isn't all that much you can
play nice to see one check is coming
night here is coming be 5v5 is coming
you just don't have the option of the
climbing this night so see capture Sundy
three and now rook the f1 threatening
Quinta a1 checkmate as the pawn covers
the B 3 square and after King III just
c5 taking away the be 4 square from the
King again this will be checkmate and
there is no avoiding this if you capture
here then Queen before it's checkmate so
you lose however you put it luckily for
Anand Magnus misses the idea of Queen e1
check followed by Knight captures here
and instead Magnus goes for Knight
captures on g6 so by playing Knight
captures on g6 Magnus basically prepares
the exact same idea
a queen e1 and the rook to f1 next now
he moved the night so the rook can get
into the action now however this is not
forced it doesn't come with check so
Anand has the opportunity to play Queen
g1 check and after let's something
something something let's say Roxy a and
the Queen covers both of the squares so
there are no immediate threats here and
white is doing well
however on and missed the idea of Knight
to g6 and this whole thing that could
have happened the move sooner and he
goes for rook to e8 but now yes again he
has a double attack on the pawn here but
now Magnus just goes for the exact same
idea that we discussed so I'm not gonna
ask you to pause the video again
Magnus plays Quinta II one with check
King to a2 and now rook to f1 and now
the same idea as being threatened and
there is nothing to be done here and
tried King to a3 but Magnus just played
c5 and it was in this position and move
38 that which one are not resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here we already shown how you how you
just cannot defend against Queen e1 mate
and again if this then just this is
checkmate
sure after this c5 move and resigned and
Magnus wins the match and he wins it
before reaching Armageddon so he again
against the three four points and since
we haven't shown any more games from
round one he also won his previous match
against Geary
so Magnus under full six points but we
are going to show more games from round
two and we are going to discuss the
standings dead so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Macduff Hughes David Turnbull
Daniel foyer
Bryce Foster and Ross Martin for a
contribution to my channel think you
want to really appreciate it as usual
you can check two of my previous video
serum thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the chest wound for legends of chess
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chest world so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day